alou capitale de la glisse étaient les
17 et 18 mars dernier avec la fête de la
glisse patronné par fr3 après l'aspect
sportif et le record du monde de ski en
randonnée voici un troisième volet
consacré au nouveau matériel de glisse
sa technologie son avenir en restaurant
serge dupuis ces dix dernières années le
matériel des sports de glisse a beaucoup
évolué notamment le surf des neiges
venue des états unis en france dans les
années 80 passer de la fabrication
artisanale à une fabrication très pointu
grâce à des programmes d'investissement
des entreprises spécialisées en la
matière celui ci le surf a connu des
formes différentes 1990 des produits
d'un concept ultra moderne de nouvelle
géométrie explique a6l la structure
monocoque donc depuis cette année on
voit apparaître une nouvelle structure
c'est une coque qui apporte une
meilleure répartition de la cuy une
meilleure prise de carre beaucoup plus
direct un retour de formation qui est
lui aussi plus direct c'est à mon avis
la nouveauté dans le ski cette année en
france 10 mille personnes pratiquent
cette discipline mais aussi le monoski
le ski traditionnel compte lui 250 mille
participants du matériel de glisse qui a
demandé cinq ans d'études et de
recherches
techniquement c'est justement cette
recherche d'une optimisation des lignes
de code pour justement arrivé à
optimiser les résultats de nos
compétiteurs
parallèlement à ça nous avons développé
des produits davantage fun puisque nous
avons développé un produit davantage
pour les spécialistes de half-pipe qui
sont qui commence maintenant à se
multiplier dans toutes les stations pour
l'avenir plus automatiser la production
de ces engins plus optimale
pour l'utilisateur de sujets parmi tant
d'autres abordée lors de la dernière
fête de la glisse de pra loup